une rue Sainte-Catherine qui grouille de
monde un village coloré qui fait une
partie de la renommée de Montréal avec
ses décorations
iconiques un âge d'or contre dire qui se
situerait entre la fin des années 90 et
le début des années 2010 Yves Lafontaine
observe l'évolution du quartier depuis
plus de 30 ans
c'est un nom manzan c'est ça qu'il faut
souvenir environ 60% des commerces
étaient barricadés dont le cycle de
splendeur et de misère le village
traverse aujourd'hui une période
compliquée où la cohabitation sociale
est un défi pour l'administration après
des annonces de fermeture de terrasses
la mairesse tient à rassurer cellule de
crise présence policière renforcée
Montréal met les bouchées doubles à sur
Valérie plante si dans le passé à
l'arrondissement Ville-Marie il y avait
un zoo d'intervenant de jour et du soir
le 7 jours sur 7 qui étaient disponible
maintenant c'est 4 depuis le début du
mois de juin alors déjà les bouchées
doubles se mettent à ce niveau là des
surprenant du programme émis piloté par
la Société de développement social il
travaille auprès des itinérants des
personnes avec des problèmes de santé
mentale ou de toxicomanie des enjeux qui
se sont déplacés au fil des décennies
faudrait pas que le village devienne un
autre ticket de rose chaque jour on
pouvait voir environ une vingtaine de
personnes qui se piquaient le parc des
vétérans était une piquerie à ciel
ouvert dans les années 90 avant des
rénovations majeures
c'est dirigé vers le parc Vigier ainsi
que qui s'est répété lorsque le square
vivait à son tour était rénové à la fin
des années 2010 il y avait ici des
dizaines de personnes vulnérables tous
les jours qui pour la plupart sont allés
un peu plus au nord aux abords de la rue
Sainte-Catherine une des solutions
davantage de ressources de jour François
Raymond fait ce constat chaque matin en
fermant les portes du centre guifavro
nous le matin à 7h quand on relâche les
85 personnes on se dit oups il va
probablement avoir des enjeux de
cohabitation derrière ça et il faudra
être patient pour assister à un nouvel
âge d'or du village ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal